hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast of assessment of animal
welfare risks of externalized animal
studies by partnering diligence and
scientific review at glaxosmithkline
presented by maryann best binder I am
Julian child of libraries and I'll be
your moderator for today's event before
we begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located on the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen what answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located to the
lower right finally if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
you're having a problem thank you now
I'd like to introduce dr. Mary Ann vast
binder dr. vast binder has worked in the
pharmaceutical industry for over 15
years she currently works as the
director of the office of animal welfare
ethics and strategy at glaxosmithkline
her team overseas animal studies
conducted on behalf of glaxosmithkline
her work includes strategic planning for
national advocacy efforts through work
with organizations such as IQ
institutional official consortium
Americans for medical progress one
health research and collaborations with
European and Asian partners dr. vast
binder received her doctorate and
veterinary medicine from the university
of florida in 1995 she attended a
residency training program at Nazca line
a state university from nineteen ninety
five to nineteen ninety seven dr. buss
under served as the attending
veterinarian at glaxosmithkline for the
Research Triangle Park program from 2006
to 2010 her professional interests lie
in animal housing global animal care and
news programs animal behavior enrichment
training and advancement of us three RS
strat strategies please
be welcoming Marianne vest binder I will
now turn the presentation over to her hi
my name is Marianne vas binder and i
work at glaxosmithkline in Upper Merion
Pennsylvania and I am here to tell you
about our assessment process for
externalize studies which is a
partnering between our external
diligence group and our scientific
review group so the names of the people
that are involved with this process are
myself Marianne fassbinder Joanne story
in the UK Mike Spangler here in Upper
Merion Brian barrage here in Upper
Merion he heads up the animal research
strategy team I'll speak briefly about
that team Tonya vanaman and Linda Fritz
are the are the my team members on my
diligence team and together we do the
reviews for our externalized studies
I'll apologize upfront if I get a little
quiet for a second I've had a terrible
cold so I'll try not to sniff and
coughing the microphone so deafening ok
so I'm a part of a group called the
office of animal welfare ethics and
strategy that's led by our chief
veterinary medical officer Margaret
Landy and we're a combination of science
income and compliance functions I'd like
to call them the license to operate more
than compliance the activities my
external diligence group really falls in
the area of quality assurance and we
also have an internal quality assurance
group that works within the office
additionally we have a risk management
program so we have quality and risk
management ethical review processes are
within the office and the training
program for anyone doing work with
animals in research the strategy for
that is within the office we also help
close the animal research strategy group
which is a group of scientists that
provide guidance for our scientific
partners in regard to scientific
challenge and doing the right studies at
the right time looking at
the right models and I'll speak to that
today looking at data sharing data
mining and then also looking into
alternatives and the 3 R's so driving in
this process is what we call policy 403
it's the care welfare and treatment of
animals by GSK in this policy is a is a
policy that describes what we expect
when one would use animals on behalf of
GSK to include some basic things like
access to food and water access to
species appropriate housing provision of
humane veterinary care housing to
minimize the development of abnormal
behaviors adherence to the 3 r's an
application of the 3 r's the ethical
review process and then adieu this is
established and that we minimize pain in
distress and that staff are trained now
would you have to remember when you talk
about studies at GSK they could be done
internally at a number of sites to
include you know in the UK the US Spain
France China and even now we've recently
merged with the company and Novartis so
we have added new sites to our group to
include india and other new China sites
so there's a lot of diversity and what
internal work is and then we also have
an immense amount of work occurring
outside the company on our behalf so
anyone who uses an animal our behalf has
to adhere to the criterion of policy 403
so why do we need a diligence process
well because first of all um you know
not all institutions for example have a
lonq accreditation you have you have a
varying standards across the world and
so what you have to do is say GSK has
these expectations and this is what
we're asking you to do and why do we
care about this well we care because
we're committed to having good animal
welfare for animals used on our behalf
we have expectations that we want them
to be upheld we also want to mitigate
the reputational risk you know we want
to make sure that we do what we say we
do in the eyes of the public because
ultimately it's the public that gives us
the opportunity to care for and use
animals and research so we want to
contain a good reputation and be seen as
a good steward for animals and then also
we want to assure that we have good
quality in our science that the site
that the that what's done on our behalf
at a third party is is is is to the
quality that we need so that we can make
decisions on the data and not just not
only for the offer but also for good
science and the purposes of good science
we know there's tremendous opportunity
out there and regard to science and even
in places where that are less known for
their science scientific endeavors but
so to take advantage of this opportunity
we have to mitigate the risks that are
involved with qatan with using these
potential organizations and these risks
could be legal that could be operational
you know what is happening on the ground
what are they doing and reputational for
the company so our program is focused on
mitigating and managing the risk with
externalize animal studies now there are
about 700 different institutions that
we've engaged with in externalize
studies and I realized that this is a
very large number compared to what most
institutions will engage but our company
is very very interested in looking at
scientific ingenuity and new sign
science ideas and so they're outlining
the scientific environment for new
opportunities so we have 700
institutions in our system and last year
that was 2015 not this year we had about
169 new submissions now this number has
varied a little bit because we've
changed the way that we are documenting
things in our database and such so it
looks a little smaller than last year
but actually it's probably a larger
number we've just consolidated some of
the records we document this information
in a database that something that was
made for us within GSK we're very
excited that were our databases under
renovation right now so it'll be more
searchable and handier to use also it's
a paper-based review for starts and then
when we start to identify the risks then
we expand out into and what other needs
might it might be what what else we'd
like to know about the institution
and we that can include a scientific
review or a site visit and collaborative
work with the company for improvements
our group is one of many groups that
work that own risks within GSK there are
13 described risks for the thirteenth
risk at the animal risk and so it's
aligned with our new third-party
oversight initiatives in the company and
it's been very interesting to be a part
of seeing how do you manage risk to
include things like you know how does
the company managed the the potential
that you know people are working in a
healthy environment or that you know
there's good occupational health and
safety programs for employees within
these third parties that we work with or
are they truly a company at all you know
that there are legitimate company so
we're aligned with that more part of
that of the third-party initiatives in
it maybe next year I'll have a chance to
speak to these third-party initiatives
in how GSK is managing them and we fit
into that bigger picture because that's
actually a very exciting new opportunity
that will be involved within the next
year so our paper-based review what is
that well it's it's driven it's been a
long time in coming and it's basically a
set of three forms and these forms are
are designed to kind of characterize
what the work is that's happening at the
third party so for example there are
three forms we whittle it down to two
now but we haven't started using just
two so we're in transition but the forms
characterize the third party animal care
news programs and then we support of its
filled out by the GSK scientist and part
of its filled out by the third party the
GSK scientist describes the work that
they're doing the science the signs that
they're doing the procedures that we've
done what animals are being used and how
many it's a very high-level brief
description and then also the
considerations for ethical review to
include preen in distress and the
procedures that are being performed so
in general we have a fairly good idea on
paper of what is the third party and and
what are what is being done on GSK's
behalf at the third party
so when someone wants to outsource a
study at GSK what would happen the first
thing that would happen is that the
investigator knows that they're
responsible for policy 403 and so they
will contact our team through a group
email Oh group mailbox an exciting new
situation with this third-party work
that's being done across GSK is that
there'll be a portal now that this
information will be would funneled in
through so anyone who wants to
externalize any work it will go through
this portal so we'll be more likely to
capture all the potential outsourced
studies right now it's we work very hard
to apply policy for our three but we
can't be sure in some of these other
sites that everyone knows about policy
four or three so this new method will
help widdle everyone in through the same
mechanism to request animal studies
which is I think will be a great
opportunity for us to capture all the
studies that are outgoing so for the
time being the investigator initiates an
email and says that they want to do a
study and they give us some title and
some details and we send them forms
through this group mailbox they'll fill
out the forms they'll fill out the form
the portion of the formula that GSK
scientists is responsible for and then
they'll send on to the third party the
form that is fairly a fairly rigorous
review of what the animal care news
program is at that institution once
those forms are completed the return to
our team and there's their finalized you
know it's much like Anika protocol
there's a lot of details that can be
left off of these forms that you know
when you do them every day you know the
things that you want to know but the
people who are filling them out for you
may not realize what you're asking and
so it can take a little bit of back and
forth trying to make sure that we get
the right information and understand
fully what's going on in the in the
third party we then convene a team
people once a week this team is composed
of two or three scientists and my
diligence team
one member of the diligence team is a
seasoned Quality Assurance person and
the other member of my team is a very
experienced animal care nice supervisor
as well as very knowledgeable about
training and other aspects of animal
care news programs together we sit down
and then I have a partner in the UK that
also joins us often because when there
are issues with the UK most the bulk of
our work is either in the US or the UK
though that there are many exceptions it
is very global but you know it is great
to have backup in the UK to help us
understand the systems and to be present
for us representing the UK processes so
this team sits down and we talk about
these protocols there's a summary that's
written by my group and there's a
discussion about what they're doing
regarding the species the duration of
the study the animal numbers the level
of pain and distress and the possibility
for for problems with the studies and
you know after this discussion if there
are any questions those questions are
clarified now during this time there are
really two considerations for any
procedure that we do and that includes
the institutional considerations and
scientific considerations so for example
institutional considerations could be
you know do they have a security program
in their institution do they have you
know or is there caging appropriate do
they have a cage wash do they you know
what and remembering that the
institutions that we work with can be
very very diverse from medical
institutions to small biotech companies
to buy medical device companies and they
can be anywhere in the world from
Australia to China to Singapore to the
US so there's just a huge diversity of
what you see in regard to Animal Care
news programs so it's it's worthy of a
good look we have gone about looking at
standards for our expectations for the
for the third parties and in general the
standards are fairly aligned with
those for the guide for caring use of
animals remembering that in the UK the
Home Office has much more stringent
guidelines than and much more less
performance and more engineering based
standards so you know in the so kind of
matching up those expectations with some
corporate standards has been an
important process for us so what I was
talking about was basically there are
two considerations for scientific for
review the institution and then the
science and the science is reviewed by a
team of by our team and we decide if
there's a scientific review that's
involved and I'm going to give a few
more details about our scientific review
process to follow this and then also we
look and see do we need a site visit and
the site visit will either be arranged
based on the institution or the
scientific need and then the there's an
approval granted that allows the
investigators to perform the work with
the third party we also are starting to
use a new process called a risk risk
rating tool now risk is actually
considered the probability of an
incident happening against the potential
impact so you know you can have high
high high incidents but low impact
events or you can have low incidents but
high impact events and so you know
really trying to balance and look at
where is the true risk for the company
and how do we manage it and we found
that there hasn't been in the past there
hasn't has been a set of criteria that
are considered but it hasn't been
formalized in any kind of way to know
well are we going to do a sites that are
not how do we know if we feel confident
about what we're doing with this
institution and so we've come up my team
has come up with a risk rating tool and
that helps us identify the likelihood
that an event will happen and the impact
and we look at things like the country
where the work is being done recognizing
that in some countries that that there
are animal laws animal research laws and
regulations in in Sutton so you know
really trying to scrutinize what's
happening in those countries it doesn't
mean that there's
good research occurring there or that
they have poor quality research means
that we need to you need to consider
them a risk because we don't know what
their standards are there are countries
where the in general the EU states have
agreed standards but those that can't
always be they aren't always implemented
in the same way so we like to do a
little more investigation in these
countries we put priority review for
species monkeys dogs and pigs get a
higher review than rodents do not
because they're less important or we
have less animal welfare but because
they have a higher impact potential and
so if primates are used there is usually
some kind of follow up on a scientific
review process pain categorization is
also a factor we look at the number of
animals used and if they're a like
accredited we have a good sense of the
standard that they're following if an
institution is aelic accredited so the
institutional aspects are concerns for
the studies are less for us when we
consider the risk this risk rating tool
will help us more consistently identify
where we want when we want to perform
site visits because you know in the past
it's been a judgment but and I think
judgement still is an opportunity in
this but we do try it it gives us a
little better tool to think about the
impact and the risk involved so our sign
visits I mentioned are based on
compliance with core principles in our
policy 403 and our our performance
standards align fairly closely with the
guide for caring use for any program
that's that we use globally and it's not
it's they're not rigid we are willing to
have a reasonable consideration for
exceptions but they need to be presented
and we need to understand them when a
site visit is performed we send a
individual out and I spoke about
institutional needs for site visit and
science needs so it depends on on what
that need is that that institution for
example if
working with a intricate surgical model
at an institution then we would send a
surgeon or a veterinarian that has
experience with that surgery to do the
site visit but we also ask them to
collect institutional facts while
they're there we have different people
in the organization that performs site
visits people in organization could be
part of our deal our glp quality
insurance group or they could be expert
laboratory animal science technicians
that are trained anyone going out to do
a site visit our behalf has to be
trained and that's documented in their
training file and then we have a
checklist format that we provide for
them before they go out that allows them
to to make notes and check off very
specific activities that we want them to
look at you know it might be you know
the floors and the flooring the caging
the cage wash area appropriate use of
sanitation so there's a whole set of
things that we check off when we look at
an institution and then there's a
recommendation made should we use this
institution or not that's that's made by
the site visitor at the time now if
there are we categorized the findings
for an institution in critical major and
minor the critical would be something
that would affect the welfare of animals
and that will get immediate attention
and stop the work being done until we
can get that issue resolved major would
be programmatic problems that need to be
addressed and managed by the institution
and will be rechecked by GSK and then
minor would be things that we would give
recommendations on but not necessarily
hold up the work for that institution
those are documented and tracked they're
called corrective actions when there are
problems identified so we have had even
recently institutions where we've
reviewed them and said there are quick
two factions that must happen before we
can continue to use this institution and
the institution is gone we agreed on
when we would revisit the site and then
have gone back to confirm that the
appropriate actions were taken in that
we were confident that the standards
were met our
Tanner's for men these segments are
stored in our database for the
institutions and can be reviewed upon
the next site visit we have frequently
used institutions for example contract
research organizations that we would use
on a routine basis for things routine
studies like you know drug metabolism or
pharmacokinetics or or safety assessment
protocols and those are typically
visited by our glp or good laboratory
practices Quality Assurance group
because they would be visiting them
anyway so that gives us a lot of it
helps us out we don't have to do as many
site visits and we get we pick up the
information from those routine partners
so I mentioned that some of our studies
undergo it all studies that are
performed on behalf of GSK need to go
through a scientific review and we
decide to gridview just oh sorry about
that guys okay the scientific review
basically is challenging the that we do
are doing the right study at the right
time in the right way so things that we
would ask our do we need an animal model
to answer this question is there
something that's in vitro that could
replace this animal model and and if we
do need an animal model what animal
model is the right model and you know
you can use a lot of different animal
models and ask the same question
different ways but are you getting to
the right answer and is that
translational to the human condition and
then what's the right study design to
balance ant balance animal use with
optimizing scientific impact so are
these studies actually providing answers
for our questions and are we asking the
right questions so our goals would be to
optimize the translational value of our
animal models and hopefully lowering the
rate of failure of our of our
medicines that were developing in our
pipeline and also to not use animal
models unless we have to use animal
models and make sure what we're doing is
creating an answer for how it will
resell our medicines will respond in the
human we're looking to effectively
leverage the internal expertise and
experience so that could be for studies
internal or external to GSK that we use
the knowledge that we have within GSK to
to improve the science that GSK has
performed on its behalf whether it's in
internal the institution or external and
making sure that we are judiciously
using animals that we are applying the
concepts of the 3 r's and that we are
truly trying to replace animals where
there are opportunities to do so and
reduce the numbers that we use so
internal GSK we have two different
strategies that we used its kind of two
tiered approach the first one that i
mentioned the team that i mentioned the
team the scientific review team at the
front of my talk and these are the folks
that are doing this work internally we
asked animal model strategy team reviews
this is an investigator-initiated but
supported by our team process that's a
hypothesis focused discussion basically
without the team and it's usually
multidisciplinary input with a standard
set of questions that are addressing the
animal models that they're using this
should occur prior to the ethical review
process this typical will happen with
severe models or models that are used
very frequently that might be severe it
might be models that are in higher
species and or you know models that were
making critical decisions on and we're
concerned or interested in the translate
ability of the of the science the other
study protocol review process is one
that's led by the investigators the tau
is is a focal group of scientists
setting one disease process and it's
hosted by the investigators and it's a
peer review process and it would be
something that's internal to their
organization and they would they would
have a protocol or form that they
typically performed on their own and it
would happen prior to
studies and as studies are designed and
developed for drug development and this
would happen for all studies that are
performed within those scientific units
and it's kind of a self driven process
and how often the scientists will come
to our team to ask about their peer
review processes and how to best
implement peer review so we can serve as
consulta tory group as a part of our
animal research strategy so if if you
continuously challenge good use of
animals that this is just a pictorial of
what I've just described that there's an
animal animal model strategy team that
then performs prospective peer review of
animal models and strategies and usually
this is leveraging kind of our internal
expertise and it can be
multidisciplinary for example you might
have a someone who does clinical trials
and human the human physician sitting on
a panel like that as well as for example
someone from drug metabolism and
somebody from the scientific expertise
area so it's a panel of people whereas
the other peer review process is really
more driven out of our worldwide
guidance that is internal to the
scientific group and it assures that
there's robust study design and
reproducible scientific methodology and
okay so back to third-party oversight
what do we do to assure that we do the
scientific review or accomplished
scientific review within these studies
because there's so many of them well
when we go through and we you know the
scientists fill out the forms that we'd
give them they're called be forms of
trying to get away from it but we can't
seem to lose the name of it there's a
scientific they have to agree that a
scientific review has been conducted in
some format and this is a yes or no
response and so that expectation is that
all studies undergo some kind of study
review now the triggers for for further
review would be if there were non-human
primates or severe category severe would
be equivalent to the u.s. category East
and so so when that happens this will
prompt a the initiation of our external
review process and so one of the people
in our team that reviews the external
studies will reach out to the scientists
and ask for further details and they'll
go through that question based process
of reviewing how we the set of questions
better animal models translate ability
how the studies are designed and
sometimes you know statisticians can get
involved and so this is a basically a
partner process so I yes so the
questions that are asked or basically
things like how well do we understand
the human condition we're intending to
model and how well is this is systemic
and molecular physiology of our intended
patient replicated in this model so in
other words you know are there more
relevant mechanistic studies that could
be done rather than doing the whole
animal study to find the same outcome
for the study how well do our models
replicate the expected pharmacology and
patience is it is are the models even
relevant do they have the same dmpk
parameters and then how well does the
model replicate the etiology and
pathogenesis of the patient disease
because in many cases the animal models
don't perfectly replicate that process
gosh I got through that really quickly
so um in general our GSK we have
oversight for institutions that are that
we do use as partners for third-party
scientific work it's a people it starts
with a paper-based review and we have a
team of experts to include Quality
Assurance laboratory animal science
veterinarians and scientists that review
the protocols that we put out and have a
chance to UM to evaluate both the
qualifications of the institution and
the science that is done on behalf of
GSK we use a risk grading tool the risk
grading tool helps us establish the
impact and the likelihood of an event
occurring and then this process is
partnered with the scientific review
process particularly if there are
primates involved or if they're high
pain and distress will go ahead and
perform this scientific review process I
had neglected to say that the that our
team meets once a week so if someone
were to put a proposal and to us we try
and turn it around within a one-week
period of time so after the scientific
review process is completed then we
determine if there needs to be a site
visit a site visit may or may not occur
and then institutions are either
approved or disapproved for use by GSK
these are all managed in an auditable
database and are part of the risk
mitigation process for GSK regarding
third-party oversight so I got through
that pretty quickly are there let's go
to questions
our moment please like grab the
questions
okay so we have one question from shadow
Thompson of Western University how our
community representatives involved in
your site visits and review processes so
we don't have community representatives
involved in our site visits this is an
internal process for review where we use
our our scientific community and our
laboratory animal sciences expertise to
review institutions that we use we do
have ethical review processes so on
going each of these institutions has to
have an ethical review process and
that's a completely separate review and
it's required of any study done on our
behalf that the institution has an
ethical review committee and that there
is ethical review for any study that we
do and so external participants from the
community are involved in those
processes through the institutions that
are third parties okay and
dobson from biopharm asks does your team
review protocols and if so how do you
deal with not delaying the research
while also reviewing close to finalize
protocol language barriers in the UK
okay so um so we don't review iya cook
protocols and that is actually one of
the critical one of the criticisms of
this process from our investigators is
that it's somewhat redundant with aya
cut protocol processes now so we don't
review I cut protocols but we do review
our templates and the information that
we need to assess and evaluate the
science that's ongoing outside of the
ethical review processes so so I'm not
sure if your question about are you
reviewing protocols no we do not review
aya cut protocols language barriers can
be a significant problem I and and the
way that we overcome that is by
partnering with the scientist and it's
just it can be very difficult for
example we have investigators in China
and things mean something different to
them when it and also they don't have
the same expectations for example we
have a very hard time aligning contracts
with China it's just a difference in
expectations in their legal language and
it's the same thing for Animal Care news
programs now that said that's one area
where aelic accreditation is
tremendously helpful because you know
that someone's been on the ground and
has looked at the programs and many many
institutions in China for example in
India have sought a lock accreditation
so that there's a sense of confidence
about the quality of their laboratory
animal programs so that that's um in a
nutshell I think that's the answer to
your question I hope I have answered
your question oh so you ask me I know
sorry you asked me how how do we feel um
how do you get past language barriers
often we can do a few different things
we have partners within laboratory
animal sciences that speak
of English and the other language for
example we have us we have sites in
Belgium and they speak French and so for
us will partner with one of our people
that works in the office that speaks
French and English and that's very
helpful or we have like key people that
speak English and Chinese in our group
that our laboratory animal scientists
that are very helpful to us and so we
can either initiate a phone conversation
or emails that provide clarity to those
questions that we didn't understand when
it comes to language barriers okay Wendy
Underwood from Ellie Lillian Co asks how
does your team ensure that a model is
valid and reproducible hi Wendy thanks
for your question you know it's a very
it's a complex process it takes a lot of
research our team has to sit down look
through all the literature and you have
to remember it's a tough position that
you're and somebody going in advising an
investigator that has expertise in that
model has long term expertise in that
model so you better be sharp on your
skills with that science sometimes we go
back and we'll look at clinicals
clinical trial outcomes and the models
that were used to compare them to how
well those animal models answered the
translate ability of the of the of the
work and there are some models that are
gaining less-populated popularity just
in general because they're just not as
predictive as they had once been thought
to be other things that we're doing is
we're working with groups such as the IQ
three hours and other organizations that
are advancing alternatives because if I
think in some cases there are
physiologic models that don't represent
the smaller pieces of what is translate
ability between an animal and a human
they're different and they're
disconnected so we're really trying to
advance some of those alternatives that
would look at the the mechanistic steps
rather than the systemic effects of
diseases but it takes a lot of research
and the other thing is just really
looking at how well have these
predictive models led to answers to our
questions and I don't know Wendy if you
can
speak to this but I would love to hear
what you're doing it Eli Lilly great
Marcia bar of Boston Scientific asks
it's a scientific review you are
discussing done for glaxosmithkline
directed interest for instance if
glaxosmithkline management has decided
to fund the work does your group have
the ability to question or change the
proposed scientific processes yes we do
actually and it can be raised up through
our chief veterinarian if we thought
that there were studies being done on
behalf of GSK that did not appropriately
represent good science or were
adequately translatable translatable or
they were something that was didn't have
scientific relevance or translate
ability that those studies would not be
done on our behalf there would be a
sit-down between the chief veterinarian
the scientific staff that have
identified the problem the investigators
and out and there would be then a
scientific review process that probably
involved for example clinicians and
other expertise that would comment on
the models that were being proposed so
yes we do have that capability it's not
a popular decision but if it's done on
behalf of the animals that's our
responsibility if there are no more
I'd like to once again thank dr. vast
binder for her presentation do you have
any final comments thank you so much for
letting me share our thoughts about
third-party oversight and I would love
to hear from you if you have methods
that you use some of the things that
we're thinking about in the future for
example reducing the number of
institutions that we work with so it's a
little more predictable on a little less
risk but then we're afraid that we'll
lose some of the interesting in genetic
work that's being brought into the
company I know that that's the approach
that many other pharmaceutical companies
have taken and I think that these are
these processes are advancing the
scientific review and really
investigating good science it's going to
be a way forward for decreasing animal
use and improving the outcomes of our
studies and City designs got one more
question thank you once again dr. Mary
Ann best binder before we go I would
like to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing or six months from today's live
event you will receive an email from
labret sledding you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share the announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again goodbye